[Applause]
oh you look great thank you you look
great oh thank you well I was told I was
pre but that was literally like what
happened and they were like and I was
like well I wasn't shocked yeah I was a
tiny bit overweight so yeah but I wasn't
shocked by but they did they were like
you're pre-diabetic you're right on the
borderline I was like but I'm not there
yet yeah exactly you got and then I
waited two years and and then did
however move into the like we're getting
close okay I'll do something about it no
but that photo the the meme was seen
everywhere that we showed in 22 did you
know that that it went it went around I
had no idea my kids showed me like I
didn't know what was going on it was it
was ridiculous but I was happy think
people were thinking of me that's all
you have literally there are so many
memes of it do you have a favorite that
you that you've seen there were a couple
that made me laugh really hard uh there
was one with like I had like a bow cut
uh and I don't remember what it said but
it just it just made me laugh it had all
the chains around my neck we had a bow
cut so right there yeah it just it got
me um but there were there were tons of
them they just and it didn't stop you
know it's funny it was it was it was
ridiculous we need to laugh yeah we do
it the shot ever and speaking of that is
there ever going to be a reboot of King
of Queens people are doing reboots I'm
just saying I'm just saying I I don't
think we can man because yeah we got
Jerry Jerry Stiller was was so part of
that show I would not want to do it
without him he it's such a huge show in
pop culture I think people are just like
hgic he's amazing it's amazing to work
with a great cast that you click they
were the greatest Leah is incredible and
uh lovely yeah show it was it was so
much fun to do and such a great time in
my life and it was like you know I get
to see it still it's on so people you
know still come up to me now younger
generation that's the thing with
streaming now people are seeing it for
the first time it's like well this is
older but yes it's brand new for you I
guess yeah yeah I had hair I I know but
you actually look pretty badass yeah
like I was good I was thinking that you
walked out I was like like no this is it
this is a look this is a VI okay it's
got to be God God made it that way yeah
no you grew up here and I just moved
here and and I love it by the way I love
it I didn't know if I would or not I was
very worried but I love it yeah it got
to be a big move for you yeah and I'm
texting at like out in the country kind
of person so it was very different for
me but what what are like some places to
eat at cuz I try and go every week
somewhere well Long Island for me I'm on
Long Island and the pizza there is is
absolutely insane Pizza is our family's
favorite okay yeah so there a bunch of
places you got to check out there
there's little Vincent in lake ronon
that is unbelievable to get me Heroes I
know every this is so sad uh that I know
lascalas the uh that's another one uh
there's branch and Ellie's Pizzeria uh
L&B spon Gardens in in in Brooklyn
someone write this down you know that
one yeah that's that's incredible you
got to go there and and when you get it
all together and you do that and by the
way I'm not against going to all of them
if you want to you know yeah toward a
pizza yes but you have to top it off
with a molted at the uh at the pharmacy
in Brooklyn the pharmacy in Brooklyn
with an F is pretty insane do you like
malteds I don't know if people like
malteds though I love a malt I don't
even bother with a shake thank you by
the way I I got them for you oh you did
yes I I wanted yeah I love this is
pretty s okay look at this okay thank
you s oh my God I'm I'm going to be
honest with you I have never had a
vanilla malt you've never had a vanilla
I've only had I've only had vanilla the
I boring and uh so here oh God how good
is that I'm going to be in trouble
because we're shooting a documentary on
me getting in shape I have to really I'm
not I wish I was joking I often tell
people because they're like oh my God
Kelly Clarkson's in shape no there's a
very big difference between being in
shape and losing weight 100% I am the
ladder yeah I am not in shape yeah well
you're very nice this should help um
thank you Brooklyn Pharmacy this is
incredible I've never had a vanilla one
I can't even focus on what you're
talking about right now I it's so good I
am lactose intolerant though so I'm
going just yeah I'm going to set this so
we all get through the day yeah just a
little bit wow sorry we're talking was
up we are back with s
James his n sorry we were just talking
so whatever his new comedy special is
called irregardless it's on Prime videos
so why title it that why irregardless
irregardless was a by the way I think
it's a word now I think it's in the
dictionary now I questioned if it was a
word people would correct me that and
say the word is regardless and I didn't
know I just would still i' throw out I
like I do that with a lot of words I
just kind of make up words and kind of
force them into situations whatever I
panic and like I you know I think I know
what I'm talking about so I'll I'll
throw out a it regardless was one and I
got I got scolded on it a couple times
and I just fought it I was like no
you're wrong and and and now I'm right
because I think it's in the dictionary
now there you go Webster agreed yeah
yeah so do you I hear that you're pretty
physical with your comedy has that have
you ever gone too far have you ever
gotten hurt or hurt someone else not in
standup so much uh I did pull a
hamstring doing like a little came out
dancing and I I did pull a hamstring and
and the rest of the show was kind of on
a stool uh but other than that pretty
safe and standup you know what's funny
is like the older I get it's like I'll
just be like walking and pull something
and I'm like what and they're like oh
what's the story I'm like no story just
getting old I guess like I don't know
what that is like reach for corn I
popped a rib in the back you know I
literally like put on my seat belt
something tweak my back I'm like are you
serious like it's it happens for me it's
age I don't know what it is but it's
like I got to keep moving otherwise also
out of shape for me but yeah we sound
like old people okay so so wait your
your tour is called owls don't walk oh
the new owls don't walk yeah yes I'm
pretty sure they do but where did this
where did this come from because I
didn't know cuz I was I was playing golf
in Atlanta and I was with a bunch of my
buddies and I hit a t- shot and it was a
horrible one it went across like two
Fairways and like rolled up against the
woods and they were laughing at me and I
grabbed my five iron and took my cart
over because I had to go punch out of
the woods and as I get closer to it I
see there's a dog sitting next to my
ball and I thought that was weird that
they let dogs on the course in Atlanta
and as I walked closer I realized oh
that's not a dog that's an owl it was an
owl sitting right next to my ball so I
thought like oh this little guy must be
hurt and I started walking towards him
and he went like he did like a move he
got like wide and then he he he was not
afraid of me and he just started walking
towards me and it freaked me out I was
like I got a five iron
here and he looked at me like that's not
enough
Club you're going to need a bigger boat
I literally got into a race with a a
foot race with an owl on on a golf
course in Atlanta so it was pretty
embarrassing so that's what I I thought
of you know for the for the really wish
there was footage of that go just the AL
coming at you and you be like wait what
my buddies wish there was I know know
that because they they were I was really
panicked I scre like girl I didn't know
what an owl could do I don't know what
you know I love owls you do I love owls
did you and how I know they're not
really but I just I own a ranch in
Montana and there's a they're big there
and they land and they right in front of
where I put Trail camps up and they
that's how I know they walk around cuz
they they walk around trying to get
stuff in the snow Yeah I had no idea but
I was huge they're Wings spanner they're
they're massive I just thought they were
intelligent you know they got the little
graduation cap and the glasses
I and very EX like their heads go around
looking around the big eyes when their
heads go around it's crazy oh it freaked
me out his head didn't move and it was
freaking me out he's just staring at me
and I didn't like it I didn't like it so
I hear this about your son uh he's
musical he plays piano right he's crazy
good yeah yeah is anyone in your family
musical like that um well all my kids
are pretty musical um I wish I was good
I can't keep him doing yeah I wish I
would have done that he loves the
classical stuff too and I'm like if you
could play get off of that stuff let's
get you got to be Billy no but no that's
a that's that's training wise like they
say that with singers guitarists piano
anybody like if you can nail classical
you can pretty much float through any
genre but where does it go what do you
do you're just playing like this
beautiful oh no no we got to make money
we got to get
out we got to don't do it for the
art no he loves it so no that's great no
I'm telling you though if he can do that
he can do anything yeah well that's good
get into some blues yeah yeah all right
well we uh we have footage actually so
let's hear it it's beautiful
[Music]
I love it it must be so cool to like
into the room and your son's playing
piano it's it's fine but what do you do
with that that's all you this what you
do show it on Kelly
Clarkson no that's like a great Outlet
even if he never goes into music having
that as an outlet is so therapeutic it
is he's good and and and again all my
kids are good so it's like it's it's
pretty it's pretty cool growing up with
them but you have one son and is it
three daughters three daughters it's a
lot of estrogen yeah you're not kidding
your boy going to be built for a
relationship they're going to force them
to be
ready it's on it really is yeah you
wrote a song I said you said you weren't
musical but I heard that you wrote a
song recently I'm not musical but I love
to think I am and I love to get out
there and try and I I partner up with a
a buddy uh of mine uh Mike Del Judas who
plays for Billy Joel you know in his
band he's just amazing and uh you know
so I'm always writing songs for him and
having him he wrote uh you know a couple
songs for me and and it's just like we
just go back and forth and play and I'll
show up at a show is see but wait you
don't use it for for anything other
purpose than you love it you love it
that's true see that's a good point
you're right all right you should listen
to yourself okay um you have good ideas
um well we need another break Kevin
specialist called irregardless it's a
word people it's on Prime video and go
online for info on his tour Al don't
walk but they
[Music]
[Applause]
do thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home